the new report from the physicians for
Human Rights it claims the Trump
administration's asylum seeking policies
are inflicting trauma on migrants the
policy was put in place by Homeland
Security Secretary Kevin McHale Lennon
who resigned on Friday CBS News has
learned the migrant protection protocols
or MTP also known as remain in Mexico
have been expanded it now requires all
asylum seekers to wait in Mexico for the
duration of their court proceedings
Mireya Villarreal spoke with some of the
migrants and those trying to help them
in Nuevo Laredo Mexico some people if
they are identified as migrants in the
streets they might be kidnapped it's
that dangerous here yeah it's that
dangerous Lee doctor fabiola pintado
with Doctors Without Borders says more
than half the asylum seekers they've
spoken to have been victims of some sort
of violence migrant protection protocols
also referred to as MPP or remain in
Mexico took effect in January and so far
has required 51 thousand people seeking
asylum in the US to wait in Mexico for
their hearings do you believe that this
program is protecting them it's not safe
for people to came back to Mexico and
wait for SLM that's for sure we're
closing the loopholes acting Customs and
Border Patrol commissioner mark Morgan
credits the program for a decrease in
enforcement action with MPP migrants are
receiving due process and protection
while the United States is restoring
integrity to our immigration system we
embedded with Doctors Without Borders in
Webber Laredo Mexico to see MPP up close
so right now we're heading to one of the
shelters where there are a lot of
migrants in the MTB program and I expect
that they will probably be on edge here
because this is one of the locations
where the director was himself a victim
of a kidnapping
this Honduran woman is part of the
program and told us her husband was
kidnapped when they got sent back to
Mexico
he was eventually released because they
didn't have money to give his kidnappers
she is stuck because it's very difficult
and we're in her home country
and here it's just as bad what is the
program done for this city I think that
they we're not prepared
ninety-nine percent of germs are never
solved Daniel Rosa is a local journalist
in Nuevo Laredo who's covered the
violence in Mexico for 20 years and more
recently has been following the issues
these migrants are facing what makes
migrants so vulnerable they have no
family
they have no papers the authorities
don't respect them so they they they can
be extorted according to a new report by
physicians for Human Rights US policies
have stranded asylum seekers in Mexico
where they are vulnerable to violence
theft and extortion by cartels gangs and
police authorities the group says 12 out
of the 15 asylum seekers they spoke to
showed signs of post-traumatic stress
disorder and children are not immune it
might actually look like these kids are
just coloring but what they're doing is
a special exercise to teach them what
parts of their body people can and can't
touch and also who they can trust I've
seen people being kidnapped twice Filipa
Reyes is a psychologist he's treated
asylum seekers for everything from
depression to PTSD how long could these
symptoms last he can last a lifetime we
caught up with the mayor of Nuevo Laredo
and he insists that these migrants are
safe in the violence in his city is
under control for CBS this morning
Saturday May Day of Y in Laredo Texas
such a difficult issue breaking look at
the looks and the faces of those of the
kids ya know and PTSD that is that a
serious mental health issue number one
for them